we're on part b
write the first four non-zero terms of
the taylor series for cosine of x about
x equals zero use the series and the
series for sine of x squared found in
part a to write the first four non-zero
terms of the taylor series for f so for
this f right over here about x equals
zero so let's just do the first part
let's first let's find the first four
non-zero terms of the taylor series for
cosine of x about x equals zero so let's
just say we'll
we'll put our kind of our formula for
the taylor series up here around x is
equal to zero so we're centering it
around x equals zero right over here and
so if we say that h of x
is equal to cosine of x
h of x is equal to cosine of x
then h of 0
h of
0 is going to be equal to cosine of 0
which is equal to 1. then if you have h
prime of x that's going to be equal to
negative sine of x and you could look
over here this is essentially h of x and
this is going to be h prime of x so it's
essentially kind of one step ahead of
where we were with g of x well we'll
just redo it over here just so it's
clear
so the first derivative at 0 is negative
sine of 0 which is just 0 and then you
have the second derivative
second derivative of h of x so
derivative of sine of x is cosine of x
but we have that negative out front so
it's negative cosine of x so h prime
prime of zero is going to be equal to
cosine of zero is one you have that
negative out front so it's negative one
and then you have
the third
third derivative of h
is equal to derivative of negative
cosine of x is positive
is positive sine of x so the third
derivative at zero is going to be equal
to zero
and then this is also and then you take
the derivative of this you're going to
get cosine of x again so then the cycle
starts again so i could write this is
also equal to
this is also going to be equal to the
fourth derivative the fourth derivative
at zero right you take let me just make
it clear what i'm saying if i take the
derivative of this i get cosine of x the
fourth derivative of h is cosine of x
again so the fourth derivative at 0 is
going to be the same thing as a function
evaluated 0 which is 1. and so the fifth
derivative the fifth derivative at zero
is going to be zero
the sixth derivative at zero is going to
be negative one and then the seventh
derivative at zero is going to be zero
so that's enough now i think we have we
definitely have four non-zero terms we
have
this term let me pick a nice color here
we have this term because we have a one
coefficient this is going to be a zero
because we have a zero coefficient this
is a non-zero term then this is a
non-zero term because we have the one
again and then this is a non-zero term
because we have the negative one so we
could say
we could say that cosine of x
cosine of x is approximately equal to
because we're only we're just
approximating it with the first four
non-zero terms so
f of 0 is 1.
so that's this term right over here
instead of f of x we're called calling
it h of x right here so that we don't
get confused with the original f defined
in the problem and that we're going to
work on in the second part of this this
section of the problem so cosine of x is
equal to 1 f prime of 0 or h prime of 0
is 0. so that there's no term there then
f prime prime of 0 second derivative
it's negative 1. so it's negative x
squared over 2 factorial
x squared over 2 factorial and then you
get another 0 for the third degree term
then you get a 1 for the 4th degree term
so plus 1. we don't have to write the 1.
let's implicitly there plus 1 times x to
the fourth over four factorial
and then the next the next non-zero term
is this negative one over here so minus
one we can just write minus and that's
the sixth degree term so x to the sixth
over six factorial and we're done those
are the first four non-zero terms of
cosine of x now let's do the second part
of the problem
so we did this first part use this
series in the series for sine of x
squared which we found right over here
sine of x squared actually i think we
wrote it
we wrote it this is the series for sine
of x squared when we simplified it
use those
use those that was found in part a to
write the first four non-zero terms of
the taylor series for f about x equals
zero so where's our function again so
our function is sine of x squared plus
cosine of x let me rewrite that
so f of x
f of x
is equal to sine of x squared
plus cosine
plus cosine of x so let's write the
first four non-zero terms and you want
to start with the lowest degree so you
could say that f of x
is going to be approximately equal to
because we're just approximating it with
this polynomial right over here
so from cosine of x
so from cosine of x you have so let me
so this right over here is cosine of x
and sine of x is over there so between
both of these the lowest degree term
right over here is this one so i'll
write this one over here
and then after that the next lowest we
then we have no in either of these we
have no first degree terms we have no x
terms but then we do in both of these we
have an x squared term actually let me
write it this way let me write it this
way to simplify what i'm doing let me
just write them out so sine of x squared
let me do this in a new color sine of x
squared is this thing this is what we
figured out in part a so that is x
squared minus x to the sixth over three
factorial i'm just write the whole thing
and then later we'll pick out the first
four terms
plus
x to the tenth
over five factorial minus x to the 14th
over 7 factorial so that's the first
four terms of that and then so this
isn't exactly that that's approximately
equal to that's approximation and then
cosine of x cosine of x we just figured
out it is plus
1 minus x squared over two factorial
plus
x to the fourth
over four factorial
minus x to the sixth over six factorial
now we can pick out the first four
non-zero terms and we since we're
assuming it's the taylor series the
first term is going to be the lowest
degree then we're going to keep going in
higher degree terms so the lowest degree
term right over here so once again f of
x
is going to be approximately equal to
the lowest degree term over here is this
one so let's write the one over here and
then we don't have any first degree
terms we don't have any just x to the
firsts over here but we have a couple x
squareds so that will actually be the
next term because we can add those x
squareds so this right over here you
have
x squared so let me just write it this
way so plus
this x squared plus this x squared minus
x squared over 2 factorial and x squared
over 2 factorial is just x squared over
2.
so minus i could write one half
x squared and i'll simplify this in the
next step but that's just going to be
one term because this is just going to
add this is going to end up being one
half x squared all right then what do we
have any third degree terms here we do
not have any third degree terms do we
have any fourth degree terms here we do
we have this
character right over here it's a fourth
degree term so plus
x to the fourth
over four factorial
over four factorial and then finally do
we have any
fifth degree terms we don't have any
fifth degree terms no x to the fifths
over here do we have any sixth degree
terms we do we have this one
and this one
so this is going to be so this is going
to be minus
minus there's a negative sign out front
both of them so it's going to be minus x
to the sixth over three factorial plus x
to the sixth over six factorial you
could say it's minus x to the 6 over 3
factorial and you could you could
distribute the negative sign if you want
i just factored it out and now we can
just simplify this thing right over here
so this is going to be equal to
so f of x is approximately equal to 1
plus
and then if you have an x squared minus
half of an x squared you're going to
have one half x squared or i can just
write x squared over 2
plus x squared over 2 and then you have
in that blue color plus
x to the fourth over four factorial and
then to simplify this
to simplify this
three factorial six factorial so this
six factorial is the same thing
just to make everything clear to us six
factorial is the same thing as three
factorial times four times five times
six
or three factorial times one hundred and
twenty and so what we can do is multiply
the numerator and the denominator here
by 4 times 5 times 6 or by 120 and then
so let me just rewrite this so i'll do
this over here because i want i want
this to be my final answer so if i have
x to the sixth
over three factorial i can multiply the
denominator by four times five times six
and then multiply the numerator times
four times five times six which is the
same thing as multiplying it times 120
so you have 120 up there 4 times 5 times
6 is also 120 and now we have the same
denominator so because this is the same
thing as 6 factorial so you have 120 x
to the 6 over 6 factorial plus x to the
sixth over 6 factorial gives you
121 x to the sixth over
six factorial and we have this negative
sign out here so it becomes
negative
x to the sixth
over six factorial
and we're done we fit we figured out the
first four
non-zero terms of our f of x